aboard a warship after a voyage across the
blue Mediterranean the doomed King Alexander
of Yugoslavia landed on the coast of France amid
a blaze of festive ovations yes Tuesday October
the 9th international tragedy began gaily in the
old city of Marseille perhaps the deepest tragedy
always opens with gaiety and festive scenes King
Alexander came on a great mission of state there
were alliances to be negotiated predominant
among all the dignitaries was foreign minister
Barthou of France the grand old man of European
diplomacy hat in hand he walks beside the king
as their powerful ally on the Balkans the French
overwhelmed King Alexander with splendid honours
from the moment of his landing here at the
pier in Marseille the king in the Foreign
Minister enter a car for the official parade
Barthou was known as the smiling elder statesman
Alexander though a man more hard and stern was
smiling to his whimsical smile was particularly
noticed that day yes but you can see Alexander
side was it foreboding in their faces you can
read the brightness that went before the black
swoop of doom the King always brooded with the
dark thought of assassination he was the most
threatened man in Europe again and again shots
had been fired at him a score of attempts had
been made to assassinate here but he may have
thought cheerily that here in friendly France
beside the French Foreign Minister he was surely
safe what hand could touch him amid a host of
French police and military guards the scene
of joy rises to climax with the thundering
acclaim of the crowd viva la Loire long live
the king the king was helping France realize her
ambition but in that triumphal scene as hitting
the hand of death tragedy approaches swiftly now
in that gala multitude lurks a man with a pistol
bound by a blood oath to kill the king he was a
Croatian terrorist and he's ready to strike and
he strikes on the running board he slashed down
by sabre strokes spraying bullets hit the crowd
women for wounded hit by the random bullets the
police overwhelming trampling somebody picks up
the instrument of death that devilish automatic
pistol the assassin straw hat lies on the ground
they had slashed and traveled him to death he had
scarcely time to know whether he had achieved his
murderous speed but he had alexander
the first of Yugoslavia lies dying here his
life cut short by the hail of bullets and foreign
minister Barthou of France was killed - trying to
shield the king and once more the Royal car rolls
on rated and funereal with the calamitous doom
this historical film document was made by
the Fox Movietone cameraman the brothers
George and Raymond maisha the French
seized it released it and seized it
again but now a Movietone thanks
to the speed of the SS Washington
is enabled to present this the most
historic film document of our time